you
hello and welcome to the 9th machine
learning in pattern recognition for use
with algorithmic trading in stocks and
Forex where we left off we were
comparing the most recent pattern which
is here to all of our previous patterns
which was here and we were generating
all the similar patterns praying them
out and also printing out the predicted
outcome in the most recent pattern we
got was a outcome of most likely to be a
drop as we look through the patterns we
could tell that they were at least
somewhat similar right and just by
looking at the numbers but it's always
helpful to kind of look at it visually
so that's what we're going to do in this
tutorial and that's going to be you know
looking at this stuff visually be very
simple to do this so the first thing
we're going to do is obviously we're
going to plot them up with matplotlib
here and so what we'll do is what we'll
do is we'll print it out print the
predicted outcome then we'll come down
here after we print it out the predicted
outcome and we're going to graph it now
the sense we have 10 digits basically
what we're going to print is X P so it's
going to be like the X right so the x
axis is always going to be same just 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 so the x axis or X
variable will always be just 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 and a 10 next up we want to have a
figure and so we'll just say fig equals
plot figure so this just kind of makes
up a figure for matplotlib to plot upon
next we're going to just do PL teed up a
lot and a blue we already imported
matplotlib as PLT yeah or PI plot is
peeled to you yeah we have everything we
need up there
come back down here where was here plot
dot plot first we want to plot X P and
then we're going to say Pat for rec next
we're going to KL T dot plot and again
we're going to plot X P and we want to
plot this time each pattern
and that's it for plotting basically the
only thing we need to do is bring it up
with a PLT dot show now we can save that
and we can run this and we drag this
over so we can see here here's the
pattern in question and then down here
this is the same patterning question
obviously and / and then this is the
pattern it's comparing it to and then
outcome is quite possibly a negative it
should have brought up a chart like this
and as you can see very similar lines so
we can close out of this it brings up
another chart and this will bring up to
the point I mentioned earlier how the
beginning is more likely to be very
similar that are more similar than the
end so as we can see here the end result
of these lines is slightly different now
this line could in theory come back up
and to further match this but it hasn't
more just comparing this pattern so
anyways that one wasn't too sexy but the
next one this is the pattern very close
especially on the end and close out that
one and then we get you know you can
keep keeping continue keeping track of
you know your outcomes here these are
the patterns that's the outcome come
back to this close this out does another
one pretty similar anyway so you can see
now here's one that were diverges at the
end again I'm just going to close
through them and get get done now um
done so as you can see now you can
display them visually the next thing
that we could do is let's say we wanted
house seemed to be maybe 8 it has to be
above 80 this time so we could look at
the ones that are purely above 80 now
we're all the only ones we can possibly
see are going to be the similar ones and
there is none there's none above 80%
similar interesting anyway we would have
seen the same patterns because
everything that was above 80 was also
above 70 so it wouldn't matter but
anyway you can see where the threshold
was somewhere between 70 and 80 so
that's going to conclude the ninth video
in the next and tenth video what we're
going to be doing is actually
lengthening this pattern obviously
really like the ten plots
is just a bit too short for a pattern
obviously it depends on your time frame
right but our time frame is very uh very
zoomed in it's a high granularity and so
it might make sense to look at longer
term patterns or at least a bit longer
of a pattern so so as we move forward
what I would like to do is actually
instead of 10 points to consider let's
consider 30 points and once we do that
we should do the same thing that we've
done and plot that up so here's an
example of one with 30 points that we're
going to be doing in the next video
where as you can see it's a similar line
a lot more variables in the line and
then there's an end divergence here
which again is fairly likely using the
method that we're doing but anyways
that's going to be in the next video as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support the subscriptions and
until next